so this was  this was the point  when eric  lost  actually no sorry  even queen g4  what am i looking at here this looks  lost  now this was the point when he lost the  game and the very very natural queen b4  holds  and the idea is because you want to go  queen e7 yeah but the point is that if  you take g5 then i have this check e7 or  queen c3 you can go queen b7 or queen c3  and pick up the pawn on f3  yeah either or you're not six by the way  so eight six he goes king g6 and after  queen e6 he wants to pick up the g5 pawn  that's his idea but  and the eval bar agrees with king g6 um  yeah  all right so looks like magnus has it  under control and while these kind of  positions i think he just never  he's so precise with with this stuff